c'est le plus important rappel de
l'histoire de l'industrie automobile aux
etats unis 34 millions de véhicules
fabriqués par onze constructeurs
automobiles des véhicules avec des
coussins gonflables du manufacturier
japonais takata fabriqués entre 2000 et
2011 qui explosent en projetant des
fragments de métal
stéphanie redmen a témoigné l'an dernier
devant le congrès américain qui
enquêtait sur cinq décès et de nombreux
blessés
en lien avec cette pièce défectueuse est
un gâchis
elle a expliqué que des éclats de métal
lui ont lacéré le visage et l'oeil droit
lors de l'explosion du coussin gonflable
le même genre de coussins qu'on retrouve
dans les voitures canadiennes explique
cet analyste
le clan des composants dans le marché
canadien dans le marché américain sont
les mêmes et fabricants fabrique pour le
marché nord-américain le même genre de
véhicule mais soyez rassurés on ne
rapporte aucun décès blessures chez nous
par courriel transports canada soutient
même qu'il n'a reçu aucune plainte de
canadiens concernant les coussins
gonflables takata plus d'un million de
véhicules ont tout de même fait l'objet
de rappels volontaires des constructeurs
automobiles chez nous dans la dernière
année en raison de coussins takata
défectueux mais contrairement aux états
unis le canada ne s'est jamais donné le
pouvoir législatif d'imposer lui même
des rappels loi donc se fier aux
constructeurs
d'où l'expression rappel volontaire une
situation inquiétante selon thomas
mulcair
quand on sait qu'il ya un danger comme
celui là il faut à gérer bref là c'est
ça la discrétion des compagnies les
américains sont en train d'agir le
canada doit également agir et rapidement
des demandes de recours collectif
totalisant près de deux milliards et
demi de dollars ont été déposées au
canada imaginez une grenade grenade qui
explose là quelques mètres de votre voix
de poitrine de loi de figure assez c'est
de ça qu'il s'agit là ces demandes
visent
quatre cent mille véhicules pour des
dommages personnels et matériels pouvant
être causée par les coussins d'effectuer
alors philippe que doit faire les
canadiens qui croient que leur véhicule
pourrait faire l'objet d'un rappel
mais la première étape serait d'aller
voir le site web de transports canada on
peut y voir on peut y consulter toute la
liste des véhicules rappelés vie sont
encore des deux tout même des
inquiétudes ou qu'on ne trouve pas
d'informations qu'on disait on peut
appeler directement le concessionnaire
ou même le manufacturier s'agit de
mentionner la marque est l'année de
fabrication du véhicule on devrait être
en mesure d'avoir l'information que vous
cherchez et puis la troisième étape la
plus importante c'est l'insee de s'armer
de patience il ya des dizaines de
millions de véhicules rappelés à travers
le monde donc évidemment changer tous
ces sacs gonflables là ça va prendre des
mois
soyez patient bons conseils merci
beaucoup philippe merci